Just finished with an appointment with my functional doctor to try to bring down my homocysteine level
She is recommended Resvera Troll 250 to 500 milligrams
per day plus and a C 600 milligrams a day any objections or concerns
Well, there's no objection to Resvera Troll
The only thing that a comment I'll make about Resvera Troll
I mean this is a good dosage and I would agree that is
That would be that may be helpful
The only thing I would say is if you could get it in smaller
Milligram capsules like 50 or a hundred milligrams capsule and split it up through the day Resvera Troll
Never all your nutrients have a half-life
Beating that okay if I take a hundred milligrams of Resvera Troll in it
Let's say I absorbed a hundred milligrams of Resvera Troll in
In what period of time?
Well now I only have 50 milligrams circulating in my body and then what period of time will I have 25 milligrams and 12.5?
That's a half-life
Out of all your nutrition Resvera Troll has been found to have the shortest half-life. It is literally a matter of minutes
So Resvera Troll is one of those supplements if you're gonna take it you want to break up the dose
so
That's my comment on that and as you know cysteine I
Don't know about that bringing down
Homocysteine levels
so
The pathway so almost as soon as it's the end path of the methaniety in cycle
Should have pulled up my chart
So homocysteine is at the end point of the methaniety in cycle that then goes into the
Transulfuration pathway and that is the pathway that you make glutathione
Edicidal cystine is a precursor to glutathione
So I guess I could see if there is a blockage in that pathway
That the building blocks of glutathione may help
I don't think it's a problem
Standard answer to this for cancer patients would be
No to the endocinal cysteine
Because we don't want to you know use endocinal cysteine to build glutathione in a patient with cancer
because you know if you have extra glutathione with cancer you do
Stand the chance of keeping the cancer cells alive
But
Sometimes glutathione can be beneficial for other reasons for short-term use so I don't see any problem with using this for a short-term use for you
at all, so
To answer your question
I don't see any objections or concerns if you're planning on doing this for a couple months to see if we can move the homocysteine levels